Alguno de vosotros nos habéis preguntado por las diferencias que existen entre
Ted Cruz y Donald Trump
No estoy de acuerdo con su política de
matar a Bart, pero si apruebo su
política de mandar al ser humano.
los dos púgiles que con mayor probabilidad de victoria están luchando por hacerse con la nominación del partido republicano
hoy vamos a verlo. Soy Enrique Couto y esto es Visual Politik.
Los dos candidatos están viviendo un
proceso realmente reñido,
de momento Trump va por delante pero Cruz
aún tiene muchas posibilidades de
acabar obteniendola nominación y de hecho en las últimas semanas está recibiendo el
apoyo del establishment del partido
necesitaremos un candidato popular que sepa manejar a la prensa, un líder que haga exactamente lo que le digamos
Ambos candidatos son conocidos por ser muy radicales y mantienen posturas comunes  en muchos campos como puede ser la
inmigración, donde ambos son prodeportaciones , prolimitaciones, promuros;
o en su lucha con lo que ellos
denominan el "Cartel de Washington", las élites políticas.
También en la lucha
contra el Isis y el fundamentalismo
islámico tienen posiciones muy
similares; pero en otros campos sus
caminos se separan por completo
hoy vamos a destacar los tres campos
principales donde Donald Trump y Ted Cruz son irreconciliables.
- Es un muñeco de Donald Tramp                                          -ala que pasada que pasada
-¿qué hace?                                                                                     - fínje ser republicano.
El primero de ellos es el más importante: la visión que tienen sobre el Gobierno,
sobre la esencia del gobierno.
Donald Trump entiende que el gobierno es una
oportunidad y que bien conducido puede
ser muy relevante para la sociedad, que
tiene que jugar un papel de liderazgo
y por ello lo que propone es un gobierno
más fuerte con una mayor dosis de
autoritarismo que sea capaz de conducir
a la sociedad en un determinado rumbo
por eso lo hice, para protegerlos de
ellos mismos
Ted Cruz es todo lo contrario
entiende que el gobierno es en sí mismo
un problema que siempre va a ser
incompetente, intrusivo e ineficaz y que
lo ven qué hay que hacer con él es limitarlo
y controlarlo
de hecho Ted Cruz propone eliminar
departamentos del gobierno federal como
son el de la
energía, el de la educación, el de la vivienda
o el comercio, porque dice que estas no
son competencias a las que el gobierno
tenga que dedicarse.
O  también propone, por ejemplo,introducir una enmienda a la
Constitución que oblige al Congreso a
aprobar presupuestos equilibrados, para
que el gobierno no pueda hipotecar a las
futuras generaciones con déficit
abultados y deuda.
por eso mi voto es para
ti, es una cuestión de ahora o nunca
el segundo punto, muy ligado al primero, es
la política fiscal. Donald Trump quiere
bajar impuestos pero quiere hacerlo
reduciendo tipos y simplificando en sí
mismo la estructura actual pero
manteniéndola sin cambiarla demasiado
respecto al gasto público lo cierto es
que es una incógnita porque Donald Trump
dice que no va a hacer recortes sociales, dice que va a incrementar el presupuesto
de infraestructuras y que también va a
gastar o más dinero en defensa. Cómo se va
enfrentar al enorme déficit de la
administración americana
bueno, nadie lo sabe y de hecho a él parece
tampoco importarle mucho.
- ¿qué van a hacer los descerebrados?                                        -les contrataremos como
empleados.
Ted Cruz, en cambio, tiene una posición mucho más consistente con su
idea de gobierno limitado: quiere realizar una
auténtica revolución fiscal
de hecho quiere simplificar todos los
impuestos en básicamente dos:
un tipo único del 10 por ciento sobre ingresos
y un impuesto sobre las transacciones de
bienes y servicios del 19%. Algo así
como el IVA que conocemos en España.
Claro, para compensar la pérdida de
ingresos que se derivaría de acabar con
la progresividad fiscal en la
tributación de salarios, en la tributación
de capitales o los impuestos
corporativos, Ted Cruz es firme, dice que
va a eliminar muchísimas medidas de
bienestar social, que va a reducir mucho
el presupuesto de los programas sociales
y que además también, como decíamos
antes, va a eliminar muchas facetas del
gobierno donde no tiene por qué actuar.
En lo más profundo de su ser ansían que
un insensible repúblicano
baje los impuestos, torture a los
delincuentes y sea un dictador.
El tercer y último punto es la
política exterior. Sí, es verdad,
ambos son unos halcones, pero con
diferencias.Donald Trump se muestra un
poquito más pragmático y dice que con
la negociación va a conseguir recuperar
la influencia perdida por los Estados
Unidos.
Así, se muestra partidario de un
entendimiento con la Rusia de Putin o
por ejemplo afirma va a conseguir
imponer un acuerdo entre israelíes y
palestinos. Y digo imponer porque Trump
dice que Estados Unidos tiene que tener
la autoridad y la capacidad para
imponerles un acuerdo.
Ted Cruz en cambio es mucho más firme en sus posiciones
a Rusia le contesta con el concepto
reaganiano de la guerra fría y respecto
a los palestinos, bueno, dice que no le
importa que él siempre va a apoyar la
democracia israelita.  Como vemos ambos
candidatos mantienen importantes
diferencias y si tuviésemos que
describirles podrán hacerlo con una
palabra: Donald Trump es el oportunista que
ha ido cambiando de posiciones
políticas
según lo requiriese su nivel de
popularidad.
En cambio Ted Cruz  es el  creyente porque
tiene una estrategia decidida de largo plazo
para recuperar lo que él considera son
valores perdidos
de hecho ha sido sorprendente pero el
propio Jimmy Carter ha dicho que
preferiría a Donald tramp que a Ted cruz
porque el primero
bueno no es peligroso es fácil negociar
con él, pero que el segundo en cambio es
mucho más firme en sus posiciones
Estas son las diferencias de Cruz y Tramp, ¿quien conseguirá la nominación? lo veremos